you've actually done some research
looking at what predicts divorce what
did you find the most long-standing
Research into a marriage and
relationships was by the gottman
institutions and they studied 10 000
couples in a lab over a couple of days
they were able to predict with 80
accuracy which couples would stay
together and which ones would get
divorced within a year and it was a
simple thing as responding to each
other's bids for connection what I mean
by this is when we have a partnership
where one person comes home and
expresses an emotion the other one picks
up on it that partnership has the base
levels to last a really long time so it
could be a simple thing like you come
home from work and say I'm so tired and
your partner says why what's wrong
simple connection from that connection
they've trust each other and then they
start to lean into each other but if you
come home and you're like I'm so tired
and your partners either says nothing or
says why are you tired I'm the one
that's been with the kids all day that
turning away from each other's emotional
needs is the training ground for divorce